Commission President jean-claude Juncker  delivered his last State of the Union  speech with eight months to go before  the European elections he called for  unity and a stronger Europe Parliament  adopted its position on digital  copyright rules with 438 votes to 226  the measures would allow artists and  journalists to be paid fairly for their  work members debated whether Hungary is  at risk of breaching core European  values Parliament asks the council to  invoke article 7 a disciplinary process  against the member state members  approved rules on cash controls and to  prevent money laundering authorities can  now track cash movements under the  current 10000 euro threshold and seize  cash if they suspect criminal activity  only 30% of plastic waste in the EU is  recycled members want all plastic  packaging to be reused or recycled by  2030 and to solve the problem of marine  litter